it's interesting that you mentioned
about description and
uh tags i guess and and the tweet and
everything because i i think over the
six years what i've learned is that i
just don't care about any of that now
and i do you care about your description
anymore no i i used to care right and
then i found out that like all the big
channels just don't do any of that they
don't put anything in the text i think
my experience there's two things that
matters title or thumbnail
that's literally the only real thing you
need to worry about tags and stuff and
descriptions and stuff
it doesn't help as much anymore and like
i i know this now because
have you guys gone through this issue
recently with youtube right where you
search for us
you search for a certain video right and
then the first three searches are
pertaining to that search and then for
some reason after about five searches it
just goes back to your recommendations
nowadays i'm just like what is the point
of the search function anymore if the
first five videos aren't what i'm
searching for then i'm just [ __ ] or
it's like viewers of your channel also
do you think
yeah that's not what that's literally
not what i search for
it's it's gone to the point where you
know back when youtube started it's just
like it's just like okay i subscribe to
the channels i want to watch youtube's
like no no no you don't want to watch
these channels
these channels and i'm like okay maybe
i'll get recommendations yeah now it's
just like i want to search for a
specific video and youtube's like no no
no no no no no you don't want to search
for that you don't watch these videos so
one of the ones that annoy me the most
is like after the fifth search it's like
here's a new video from someone you
subscribed i'm like what is the point of
the subscription
i can check that there is an entire page
for that what is the point of pages now
because all pages are just going to
become the same page eventually exactly
so annoying like what is the point of
the search bar so yeah like to me like
descriptions and tags don't mean as much
anymore it's it's all about title
thumbnail viewer retention because it's
all
recommendations we all bow down to the
almighty algorithm yeah that's and
that's unfortunately like
that's unfortunately what you've got to
do to be a youtuber nowadays yeah pretty
much i mean i guess it does make sense
that it should be you know what you say
and what you create and not necessarily
what you're typing into the description
right i mean every time that i see for
example some of my gem mates they just
throw up a schedule nothing in the
description i'm like wow what a bunch of
chads
it doesn't matter but i mean i don't
know i guess i'm still there's still
some things i'm figuring out you know
day by day i've gotten a lot better than
i was in the past um and i feel good
about that so you know day by day though
you can always learn new stuff
especially in this job i feel like
you've won like a shitload in just a
year
considering
what you've learned in this year and
what you've done in this year it's
actually insane yeah
i look back on some of the years i've
had on youtube and i'm just like i'm
doing [ __ ] nothing
how do you mainly would you say you
learn things on streaming and youtube
did you learn from other
gen mates or do you learn from outside
of uh hollow live or do you learn on
yourself i'm curious
where you kind of pick up this stuff a
lot of times it's like a feeling that i
get like after i'm done with a stream i
can feel whether it was bad or good oh
no yeah i agree
what i did wrong this technically wasn't
good these people were angry about this
etc and it's all my mind you know and i
also i'm very receptive to criticism but
something that i also learned is that
not
every criticism that you get that is
framed politely is necessarily correct
that's a lie that we tell ourselves to
so that we don't come off as butt hurt
babies but the truth of the matter is
you don't need to 100 take every single
critique that you get from every
anonymous person on the internet even if
it's framed nicely you need to be able
to discern
what is actually going to help you and
what isn't but one thing that you
shouldn't do is lash out i would say
that that's oh yeah yeah that's a given
yeah never feed the trolls
just never ends up well you know there
are people that get excited uh when i
talk about them than the bad things they
say and the thing that you do is you
don't give it to them and you just
ignore them i mean yeah it's rule number
one don't yeah don't forget the truth
that's another thing i have to learn as
well along the way you get do you get
like when you started off did you did
you get like a lot of advice from maybe
your fellow gen mates or you know cover
itself about
what to do in terms of like how to
handle your content and just like
general advice to be a content creator
in general was it all just like trial by
fire uh
you know
you know i'm gonna be honest with you
we really were just kind of they just
said go you know and i think that part
of that is because in the process of
selecting us they made sure that we
would be okay with that because all of
us that have like gone through it
have not there hasn't been like a huge
disaster or anything like that with us
in terms of streaming everyone has a
good handle on themselves and i think
you got to give it to um to uh i guess
who chose us um for that uh specifically
that they did choose people that have a
handle on how to do things however that
isn't to say that we were all
experienced streamers in the beginning
yeah that's definitely not the case i
had barely streamed in my entire life i
was mostly making music in the shadows
yeah yeah quite different you know
extremely different but but somehow they
knew that i'd be able to handle it
somehow and you learn a lot of things
along the way but in the beginning we
all did have the ability to get through
that starting line you know but we
didn't get a lot of advice i will be
honest i think one of the biggest things
you have to learn which a lot of people
maybe might not consider is the
technical side of things because like
with a youtube video you know if
something technical happens on set or
something some things you could kind of
save and post
there is no getting around technical
issues on stream and i feel like the
only way you've really learned is when
it happens on stream and you're just
like well i guess i just have to learn
not to do that again right exactly stuff
breaks a lot as well yeah i'm all right
yeah damn so so you mainly did a lot of
it on your own you you learned
everything
wow so when you when you started off
there was nobody who was like hey by the
way people might just say like bad
things about you for like no reason that
might just happen just like it's gonna
happen no one told you there was a
question um that i will i will say
because it's kind of obvious that they
would ask us this okay um people are
going to say mean things about you and
hate you are you okay with that and
obviously all of us got in
we all said yes but i remember a
question
my answer specifically was well i've
dealt with that with my music before um
you know before all of all of this i did
indeed have people that would come
around and do a little bit of trolling
so to speak um and
i felt like i had dealt with them pretty
well by just not saying anything and i
feel like um i thought to myself that
should be fine when i enter holo and
it's been fine um so that's okay for me
um you know everyone's experience though
is different i would say so yeah i i
think as well there is the
added uh very scary aspect of being uh
what again this is just my perception of
being a youtuber everyone is just like
trying to find out as much personal
information about it yeah
whereas everyone can just see that i'm a
teenager now and
yeah
i feel like although people are
definitely trying you know people try
and get on personal information but i
don't feel like it's intense yeah like
at least i don't see it maybe i'm just
too lazy i'm not looking but yeah
or you've already shown everything
because like one one thing i've always
been curious about is like do you feel
pressure to have to keep like say a
certain image of yourself or you know
your audience or just the general
perception of youtubers because we we we
obviously keep a certain image but i
don't i feel like it's nothing on the
same level as what youtubers have to go
through right it's rough because i feel
like one thing that i learned is at the
end of the day i've got maybe about 80
percent of a fan base that really really
want me to be 100 just myself i see them
in the comments all the time saying
you're doing great cali just you know
loosen up a little bit in the beginning
right for example you guys saw when i
first came here i was i was trying to be
something that i wasn't like
um yeah yeah it was quite strange but it
turned out good it was not it was good
it was a good episode of my development
we literally saw the development on the
two-hour podcast exactly exactly and so
you know
for those for those people saying just
be yourself kelly i gotta say thank you
because it was because of comments like
that i realized hey maybe it's okay for
me to loosen up a little bit relax you
know people wanna see who i am for who i
am and that's great but of course you're
gonna get you know a small but loud
minority of people that want you to be a
certain way and you just gotta deal with
it i personally have found um i think
like a happy medium where i'm still
being myself but i'm not you know going
into territory that would make others
angry you know
like viciously angry you know of course
because i feel like when comments tell
you to be yourself it's kind of like a
trap because like they want they want
you to be yourself but not yourself
don't like i'm just like the worst
person
i think when they say you should just be
yourself they what they actually mean is
be yourself but the version that i like
yeah exactly right exactly
but i try to look at it in like a
positive light you know and just do the
best that i can to be uh the best me and
um and just stay positive i've found
that uh negativity tripped me up a lot
in the beginning and um
i've been i've been trying to you know
smile through even the difficult times i
know sounds cheesy anime as hell i guess
small small food of tears just small
through the tears
those are the ending songs
[Laughter]
yeah definitely
but i feel like a positive outlook is
good and necessary if you want to keep
doing this for a long time and um so i
feel like things have gone pretty well
and i'll just keep all i can keep doing
is being the best me because at the end
of the day no matter what someone's
going to be angry at you for something
and if people are constantly going to be
like be this way be this way and
constantly upset the choices that you
make why not make the choice that you
want to make and just deal with it from
there yeah you know it's nice because
when i'm
when we met you on the podcast i didn't
really know of your streams at all i've
seen it a little bit
and definitely now even throughout the
year when i check in it seems like every
single time i've watched your streams
you just seem more comfortable and more
yeah